hey crazies sometimes math is
unavoidable without it you miss out on
important insights so what if instead of
avoiding math we try to visualize it I
want to give you a glimpse inside my
head for a few minutes this episode was
made possible by generous supporters on
patreon okay so the math I want to help
you visualize today is divergence and
curl but this isn't a math channel it's
a science Channel we need context fluid
flow seems like an obvious choice but
those aren't always simple like this
sometimes they're rather complicated and
if we're being honest I don't really
understand fluid mechanics as much as
I'd like to I'm trying to teach myself
but that takes time so we'll reserve
fluid animations like this for analogies
only let's focus on something I happen
to know a lot about the electromagnetic
field which is actually a combination of
two different fields an electric field
shown in blue and a magnetic field shown
in orange we did a whole series on how
we discovered those fields and what they
do but I didn't talk about divergence
and curl at all and I think that was a
mistake so it's time to fix it we have
two behaviors divergence and curl acting
on two different fields electric and
magnetic that means we need four
equations they look something like this
the Maxwell Heaviside equations which
most people just call Maxwell's
equations don't get me started
but these constants are just there to
make the unit's work out they're not
actually important for understanding the
equations so I'll just set them all
equal to one but do what I want all
right as we go through these one at a
time we'll look at the equation first
and then we'll see what we can do about
making it more visual let's start with
this one also known as Gauss's law it
says the divergence of the electric
field at some point equals the charge
density at that same point in other
words the reason the electric field
isn't just zero everywhere is because
electric charge exists but this law
tells us something about the shape of
the field to say we draw an imaginary
sphere around some region of space the
outer surface of that sphere has
electric field arrows sticking in or out
since that sphere is imaginary we could
make it any size we'd like but to find
the divergence we need to make that
sphere really small like just a bit
larger than the size of a single point
kind of small you're such a little
adorable sphere yes you were
yes you are anyway the divergence of a
field tells us how much that field
points away from that tiny sphere if the
field points into the sphere as much as
it points out then the divergence is
zero
Gauss's law tells us there's no charge
at that point if the field points more
out of that sphere than in the
divergence is a positive number
Gauss's law tells us there's positive
charge at that point if the field points
more into the sphere than out the
divergence is a negative number
Gauss's law tells us there's negative
charge at that point electric charge is
the reason the field looks like that of
course that's all very static and a
little boring if it helps you can
imagine this electric field is the
velocity field for some fluid instead
that way it's easier to see the inward
and outward directions at any particular
place but it's important to remember
this is just a visual tool nothing is
actually flowing in this picture there's
no electromagnetic fluid it's not a
thing we can interpret the other
divergence equation the same way it says
the divergence of the magnetic field at
some point is always equal to zero so
unlike with electricity there's no such
thing as magnetic charge in other words
there are no magnetic monopole magnetic
poles like north and south always come
in pairs consider the magnetic field
around this bar magnet using that same
imaginary sphere the divergence is how
much the field points away since the
divergence of the magnetic field is
always zero there is always just as much
field pointed into the sphere as there
is pointed out of it no matter where we
put that sphere this becomes pretty
obvious using the fluid analogy every
stream line that goes into the sphere
comes back out that's all there is to
divergence the curl on the other hand
why does this keep happening curl is a
different story your first instinct
might be to imagine those clothes fluid
loops again and that's certainly an
example of a curl but this flow has a
curl too without loops of any kind
that's because the curl isn't really
about the field itself it's about what
the fields might cause in this fluid
example say we draw a tiny imaginary
circle somewhere on the screen oh come
on man
if we imagine some kind of paddle
attached to that circle the difference
in flow between the top and bottom will
cause it to spin so even though the
field itself doesn't circulate the
things inside it will now let's get back
to electromagnetism Faraday's law says
the curl of the electric field at some
point equals the negative change in the
magnetic field at that same point say we
draw a tiny imaginary circle again and
we notice a magnetic field passing
through that circle if that field is
changing over time Faraday's law tells
us there must be an electric field that
curls around the imaginary circle the
curl of that electric field will be
opposite the change in the magnetic
field but remember the curl isn't about
the shape of the field it's about what
the field might cause if our imaginary
circle happens to be a metal ring we'll
get a circulating current that result is
what matters so where was away again
divergence of the electric field
divergence of the magnetic field curl of
the electric field all right there's one
equation left the curl of the magnetic
field it's pretty obvious from the bar
magnet example that the magnetic field
curls but let's take a look at MPs law
and see what it actually says a curl in
the magnetic field at some point can
happen for one of two reasons an
electric current passing through that
point or a changing electric field at
that point it's the longest of the four
equations which is why I saved it for
last
we can handle this say we've got an
electric current in a wire if we draw
our imaginary circle so electric current
passes through it and peers law says the
magnetic field should curl around that
circle now let's say somewhere along
this wire we've got a capacitor it'll
act like a gap in the circuit which
means no static current which means no
field unless that current is alternating
alternating current or AC opens up a lot
of possibilities for us since the
current and the wires is changing on
either side of the capacitor the
electric field inside the capacitor is
also changing that changing electric
field creates a curl in the magnetic
field around our circle just like the
current does in the wire this keeps the
behavior of the magnetic field smooth
across the entire picture there's a curl
in the magnetic field all along the
circuit chain so what's the best way to
visualize Maxwell's equations using tiny
imaginary shapes and a little imaginary
fluid divergence tells us how much a
field points toward or away from a point
in space for electric fields that's
caused by charges for magnetic fields
it's always zero so we know magnetic
poles always come in pairs curl tells us
which way something inside the field
might spin or circulate in
electrodynamics that means we'll
probably get some kind of electric
current just remember those shapes are
imaginary and that fluid isn't really
there they're just tools to help us
visualize the math so what do you think
should I do more videos like this please
share your thoughts in the comments also
maybe answer the poll that pops up over
here somewhere if you want to see the
actual math of divergence and curl
there's a whole chapter in my e-book on
vector calculus big news though it's a
physical book now what I know right it's
crazy it makes it feel so much more real
to me it's available through lulu.com
which helped me keep the price
reasonable links for both the eBook
version and the physical version can be
found in the new bleedy thanks for
liking and sharing this video don't
forget to subscribe if you'd like to
keep up with us until next time remember
it's okay to be a little crazy
chaos fever mentioned that in Greece
they call the Nablus symbol upside-down
Delta it's kind of cool actually cuz
that's exactly what it is but when I
type that Greek word into Google
Translate it says it means lazy I wonder
if they're trying to say an upside-down
Delta is lazy anyway thanks for watching
[Music]